and so you look at these pictures like I
was looking at my yearbook picture and
all like all the girls are just you know
it's just this huge frizz thing and I
actually had I can't believe I'm saying
this on camera I actually had a mullet
hi and welcome to another episode of tea
with teachers I'm here today with
Professor irani Ghazi hello I know you
did a ton of music things when you were
here you talked a little bit more about
that right so like I said I play
clarinet and when I got to MIT I just
loved it there was there's a ton of
music here it's one of these best-kept
secrets of MIT so I was in Orchestra and
chamber music and took a lot of the
music classes you know so I was a music
minor and it was really great but for a
long time music was sort of separate
from engineering for me you know as
korsak's did all the classes took music
classes but they were kind of in two
different buckets and then when I was a
senior I did a Europe at the Media Lab
and that was pretty awesome because it
was with the music group there with Todd
Mac over and that was the first time I
got to do music and technology at the
same time so I totally loved it when
that happened I kind of knew you know
this is this is finally my colleague
seeing of that I I brought a little
something oh right yeah it's the Wii
version yes but we version of something
that you have created yeah funny yeah
rock band and guitar here haven't seen
one of these in oil yeah yeah what do
you want to know I would love to know
what is your favorite song to play on
rock band or Guitar Hero so honestly
like my favorite songs are are the
Beatles songs that we did for Beatles
rock band this is a fun question so
given the choice of anyone in the world
Dead or Alive
who would you like to have as a dinner
guest I think I would want to have
Leonard
your guests so amazing musician
conductor composer everything but in
particular he he developed these series
of of lectures that he he videotaped and
you know there was like this series
about him explaining how music worked
you know and sometimes he just be at the
piano talking about my Beethoven
symphony and sometimes he have a whole
orchestra in front of him and he'd be
able to point out different things so
those Bernstein lectures and music were
really fabulous and I don't know if
there's anything like that right now but
I'd want to go back and it's like how
did you do that what made you think of
doing that because the generation of
people who watch that I think gained a
tremendous amount from from those and
being able to understand like oh that's
what the composer was thinking when he
wrote that yeah what advice do you have
for students like at MIT who might be
super super passionate about a project
that other people are like this it's not
practical what are you doing go get a
real job you know like what advice do
you have for students who are not
immediately successful well so the the
first thing to keep in mind is that
you're young and you have you still have
quite a lot of time before you
necessarily need to be like responsible
right
and by responsible I think I mean
towards towards someone else you know so
either to your spouse or your
significant other or your kids right and
so it's a great time to take risks when
you're right out of school so I think
everyone should be doing stuff that is
risky that oh but and by risky it means
that there's a decent chance of failure
at this point you should be really
finding the thing that you love to do
more than anything else and it's
sometimes hard to find what that is and
so if you don't know what that is yet
then keep looking
[Music]
thank you for watching this week's
episode of team of teachers if you like
what you saw subscribe and watch more
videos here follow us on social media
here if you have suggestions for
questions or professors let us know down
in the comments below
have a great week